elle est passée à côté de moi sans un
regard plein de sava ina japon que c'est
pour toi aussi les bijoux les fruits
bien mûrs au bout de bienne m'a dit
aïcha si tu m'aimes
[Applaudissements]
est elle si elle fait adore recherchait
ve aa
à mon avis ça va ça va très dans le sac
le dira en sortant du radeau quoi qui
flottera parce qu'on aura de deux 2
candidats de noyade la semaine derrière
qui viendront tout nu 1 sur ce plateau
c'est toujours un bonheur d'avoir deux
trois personnes détenues ça fait
toujours un petit peu d'ambiance un
petit peu de piquant sur toi côtés de
nelson monfort je vois une quête
[Applaudissements]
on accueille des invités des leçons de
montfort et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci des fluctuations elle m'a dit
comment ça ma famille est là nicolas bon
on va revenir à bien sûr sûr sûr votre
aventure puisque ce soit il y aura donc
recherché vous avez eu cette bosse tous
les deux non mais franchement
et puis cette opération camouflage là
avec on va très bien nelson auriez dû
dire qu'après quand vous aurez
heureusement que vous avez éviter
justement là l'inversion des rôles a
commencé vraiment d'elle ça va être un
très habile à lui c'est un fou de col
roulé je le connais il adore ça allait
nora et del sol ah oui elle fait très
bien partout oui effectivement regarder
l'épisode toujours classe a alors dit
moi alors oui alors et doit rentrer dans
la tête rentrée dans la pièce rentrer
dans le jeu leur entrée dans la pièce
allez-y retrait retrait il y à des
serpents il y a des mygales il va
falloir que vous formiez une phrase en
trouvant des mots sous les mygales et
les serpents
si vous arrivez à le faire et bien un ou
téléspectateur gagnera une console de
jeu et nora et nelson c'est parti et
laura vous pouvez laisser tomber les
clés c'est parti on y va essayer de
trouver allez on y va
ce qu'il faut essayer de trouver sous
les animaux la démo c'est que vous avez
les mots vous allez devoir trouver une
phrase d'accord alléger les noirs
moi je vais je bien commencé les cours
plus que je vais déjà faire les aidera
live alors re sic et leur a donc soulève
un de ses amis jaune et blanc mais pas
non mais si c'est en dessous que ça je
deviens toi je n'ai pas le courage de
mettre ma main dans le sac au delà on
voit pas ce qu'il a il ya une sorte
d'énorme à rien ça dans la vie des
adolescents miley cyrus a vendu ce genre
de show pré jour je veux bien rappeler
n'est pas collée dessus mais sony pour
m'aider je t'aime
ce n'est pas le seul à aller à la la
adelson hydrologie vais j'y vais mais
bon sang vous y allez la dette sociale
je veux pas imaginer je nettoyais rien
du tout
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi alors deux jeunes supporters
des serpents je n'ai pas peur des sports
ben c'est gagné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]